[Music]
we thought that we would open it up to
questions and we have a roving
microphone around here so we here oh
yeah he's back Mattie's raising her hand
yeah
uh-oh there we are right here yes please
what's your name
Carrie Archer you can play my friend
bring me here
I really enjoyed tonight I have a
two-part question are your children on a
plant-based diet and how do you do with
other people's constant curiosity if
they are on a plant-based diet
mhm you want to start do you want to
start with that or yeah I didn't send
the second part of the question how do
we deal with did we pay do you mean
being weird
I'll be straight how do you do with
tables now I'm not weird at all but how
do you deal with people's negativity I
give you yes I mean yes yes bla bla bla
okay yes baby killer thing the baby
killer yes yes cartoon all of our
children are vegan yes and it's been a
you know it's been a journey for all of
us we didn't start off weren't born we
didn't give birth to a vegan family like
that's exactly how it happened so just a
you know quick summary is I was raised
on game meat in Alaska my dad was a
hunter so I had that experience and then
I as you guys heard in ridge's talk I
healed myself of assists in my neck
using Ayurveda which is primarily a
plant-based diet and some very potent
herbs that were very aromatic but I was
you know I was at very healthy
vegetarian rich was eating very
unhealthy processed foods one of our
sons has always been naturally
vegetarian and the other son was eating
what we used to call clean meat and then
our little girls which you know my boys
are a different dad it's a different
marriage so they used to go half time
with their dad and he would try to shove
in them and then I would get them back
so we had that thing and then rich and I
had have two little girls that I give it
we had together and they have always
been vegetarian and they became vegan
later after rich went vegan and really
the way that we did it is we've allowed
each family member their own journey and
we really are careful to be respectful
and to cultivate unconditional love in
our kitchen I think if you brought
violence into your kitchen you've you've
missed and we have to be very careful as
parents that we don't start creating
eating disorders and our children
because we're so freaked out about
everything they're eating so we're kind
of loose we kind of flow but I make a
lot of amazing vegan meals we let
everybody have their own journey as
early as a month ago my nine-year-old
wanted to try an egg nice and fine
order the egg she tried it she didn't
like it but it's her experience she owns
that experience so if we go to a
birthday party and our kids want to have
a piece of pizza where we let them have
that autonomous decision what they do
and then later when they don't feel good
or they have a stomachache or they
remember the environmental consequences
and they talk about it
we can retrace that and give them that
experience so that they invited so in
other words we try to not create
rigidity around rules about what you can
and can't do because when you do that
you plant a seed for a later rebellion
especially with a young child who then
becomes a teenager and there's something
to resist against right so instead of
that like Julie said it's about autonomy
but it's also about trying to keep
create and foster and cultivate a
meaningful emotional connection to not
just food but where food comes from why
we're eating certain foods and not other
foods so everything is sort of an
evolving organic to use a pun
food homeschooling experience from going
to the supermarket to the farmers market
to why we're choosing this food and not
that food we bring the kids into every
aspect of that equation and then when we
get home the kids unpack the groceries
we involve them at a very young age in
the preparation especially of the
evening meal so early on they're
learning how to make recipes and when a
young child knows how to make a healthy
recipe there is a sense of agency that
comes with that that creates that that
bond and that emotional connection then
they want to make it they're proud of it
there's a self-esteem that comes with
that and my feeling is that and Julie's
feeling is that that creates patterning
for long-term success so it's not about
what they're doing in the short term
they want to experiment with an egg or
or try the chocolate cake at the
birthday party it's what are they doing
20 years from now right what is the
long-term goal and trying to set them up
for that kind of success and
understanding that progress in order to
progress appropriately and responsibly
you have to forsake this idea of
perfection like you're going to have
this perfect child is going to like eat
vegan 100% of the time I don't know if
that exists in Planet Earth maybe it
does but it hasn't been our experience
so that's kind of in a nutshell how we
do it and then what do you how do you
address the baby killer thing well I
just wanted I want to wrap that up also
the other thing that I think is really
powerful and it's been kind of my my
processes I don't get him motional e
involved in my children's likes and
dislikes like if my child shows up and
I've you know I prepared some Brussels
sprouts and she says mom I hate Brussels
sprouts I look at her and I go yeah I
get it
like okay I hear you and then the next
day they'll be Brussels sprouts on the
table I don't and I'm not being
disrespectful
but I just I'm listening to her but I'm
not going to change the way that I'm
cooking in the kitchen because she
doesn't like something so what I do is I
keep making lots of varieties of whole
foods whole plant-based foods and so
what happens is the tribe is just around
the experience and they're all grabbing
whatever
and then in a month she has a full plate
of Brussels sprouts and she's leading it
so again we have a lot of this emotional
battle around food and if you just you
just remain neutral and don't get
involved in it it can be very very
powerful and I just feel again you know
we have to allow people their own
experience including our children and
finding their own way and all of our
kids kids are vegan by choice they all
cook my 13 year old who is very sassy
and 13 ish much to my really shocked she
chose as her semester project
plant-based Italian cuisine and she
creates some pretty amazing recipes so
even if you think they're rebelling or
they're not seeing you know it's a whole
lifestyle so how do we address the
negative people I would say that that
experience is an opportunity for you to
reflect on your commitment to your own
personal instinct and mission right it's
like a mirror for how strongly you feel
about what you're doing it's like a gut
check on that because if somebody's
expressing displeasure or judgment at
some choice that you're making that
really speaks to them rather than you
right so how you take that I think is a
reflection upon where you're at with
yourself with the behaviors that you're
engaging in and you know like I said in
my talk I was on the receiving end of a
fair amount of that throughout my
journey and then Julie kind of alluded
to some struggles and challenges that we
had as a family and we were on the
receiving end of a lot of judgment from
external circumstances and I think that
that ultimately brought us closer
together as a couple and as a family
because we were so committed to this
vision and this journey that we were on
but because we shared that we were able
to have that experience if you're not
certain it could it could tear you apart
just as equally I think so it's a very
powerful it's a very powerful thing and
I think in order to properly weather it
you have to really know what you're
doing and believe in what you're doing
and
and be in a place where you've done
enough internal work that you can really
trust your instincts about this journey
that you're on yeah and I think I don't
know financer I think just to add to
rich I think again we have to remember
that our power as beings is in neutral
loving compassion and everybody has
their moment you know it's it's not a
fun a battle and it's for me it's not an
ism you know once you've made it an ism
you've created a set of rules that leave
someone on the outside so this is your
process of your life and you can listen
to other people's experience just like I
listen to my daughter tell me she hates
Brussels sprouts and not get involved
emotionally and scream back at her yes
Brussels sprouts are awesome so just be
in your own process create a lot of
healthy you know choices and shine be a
shining example show up at your friends
with amazing dishes that you make blow
their minds and don't get caught up if
they're if they're still eating meat or
if they eat something that you don't eat
you know you just navigate your way
around it respectfully and you know
honor everybody in their own journey
imagine if you're only eating potatoes
well what kind of judgment kind of you
black to evening you get a Greek family
not going to thank you you do dance to
it thank you so do we have the roving
microphone
ah yeah hey hey guys how's it going hi
here we are there we go
and my question is also in two parts and
then it's too rich and primarily and I
listen to your podcast and obviously
back when you're a lawyer and you're
quite overweight before you got into
exercise who is the who's kind of one
person that you never thought you'd have
on the podcast and then the second part
is and where do you get your protein
notes and the second part is and when
was the kind of tipping point obviously
you've built the podcast up over three
or four years when there's a kind of
tipping point when you went oh this is
kind of like a big thing it's a big deal
cool thanks for the question well who
did I never think that I would ever be
able to have on the podcast that answer
is obvious but fit of course right I
don't know it's a good question I've had
the opportunity to interview and spend
time with some pretty remarkable people
I've joked about this before but the
podcast is like the ultimate scam
because it gives you this excuse to call
up and pester amazing people and
convince them to sit down in front of
you and you can hold them hostage for a
long period of time and ask them
questions and they willingly oblige it's
unbelievable so yeah I've had the
opportunity to interview like Arianna
Huffington and Steve Case the founder of
AOL and like Biz Stone the co-founder of
Twitter like people that have really
shaped culture in a very profound way
and those are meaningful experiences to
me but perhaps not the most meaningful
of all the gifts that I've had you know
I really the people that I resonate with
the most and have meant the most to me
to have on are the anonymous people that
are doing amazing things you know not
necessarily in the public eye you know
people like Josh ladawna who I've had on
and David Carter who have you know
basically overcome incredible obstacles
to do interesting things for no other
reason that they made a commitment to
themselves and I take a lot of joy in
being able to put a microphone in front
of somebody like that and
and and allow them to share their you
know their personal story with a broader
audience so hopefully that answers your
question in terms of the second part
there was no tipping point really it was
really just a very slow organic growth
curve there wasn't like one interview
that I had that like blew it out and put
it on the map in any big way and I think
it's kind of a beautiful example of the
same approach that I've applied to
everything from training for the races
that I've done or you know whatever I've
tried to achieve in my life it's like
just consistently showing up and putting
in the work you know and divorcing
yourself or removing your emotional
attachment to the result and just
continuing to show up to show up to show
up consistency carries the day and I'm
very proud of the fact that over 4 and
1/2 years of doing the podcast like I've
never missed a week like I've always
been able to put up a show they're not
always going to be the best shows or
whatever sometimes it's all over the map
but like continuing to show up to show
up to show up and I really believe that
that is a huge aspect of the success
equation for the program yes who's got
the flank there we are
firstly thanks a lot both of you um for
just like you know opening up the door
to your lives and I know I'm probably
speaking for everyone in the room one
truly inspiring to just stand here and
like listen to this story
and obviously the podcasts are amazing
so please never stop my class lead off
at some point nah man keep it going my
question is you know with the topics
that you raised rich in your podcasts
you know some of them are pretty
hard-hitting on a global standpoint as
well as when you touch on I guess
specifically in the US how do you you
know and you've obviously done your
homework when before each podcast
because your line of questioning is
quite you know you take them on a
journey how do you not get like severely
emotionally attached to the content that
you deliver because you know the last
one what the hell you guys are doing
some amazing things how do you
drop everything and say I got to do
something more than what I'm doing
because these are serious issues or you
know the the clothing industry and just
all these things that are like global
massive issues how do you have that not
get to you and then second question
sorry for the two parters but what's the
what's the next step for both of you
because like you've had so many arms of
your you're kind of like progression you
know with the retreats and the books and
the podcasts what's next mmm yeah thanks
your question I do get emotionally
involved in attached to the guests that
I have on that's like my criteria for
having them on in the first place like
I'm not interested in having somebody
come on and share some amazing message
and being immunized emotionally from
that or behaviorally like I want I'm
doing it because I want to grow and I'm
interested in what they have to say and
I want to change and I want to be an
agent of that change so when I'm looking
for guests to have on the show I need to
they need to like emotionally can you
know I need to be able to emotionally
connect with that otherwise it doesn't
work for me and it's not going to be a
good show anyway but I think what you're
getting at is that there has to be a
level of self-care you know you can't
just oh my god you know what are you
going to do throw up your hands like I
can't wear these clothes anymore and I
can't eat this food and I can't do this
and I can't exactly there's a paralysis
that can like descend upon you where you
feel like everything's [ __ ] and like
what you know what's the what's the
youth so I always kind of think to
something gene Baur said to me gene Baur
being the founder of Farm Sanctuary he
said you know he was talking about
veganism but he was saying it's
aspirational and I think that's
applicable to any kind of lifestyle
change that you're trying to make like
we're aspiring to be better and that has
to come with incremental behavioral
change so whether that applies to the
food that's on your plate or the you
know the consumer products that you
choose to you know put your dollar
towards the idea is to be more mindful
to do a little bit better tomorrow
you did today to be that agents of
change and I try to incorporate those
ideas and practices into my life and use
the podcast to activate as many people
as I can
with the understanding that I'm not
perfect and you know I'm not going to be
able to you know just live like a monk
in the world and that the podcast is
going to reach however many people it's
going to reach and it's going to
activate however many people that it's
going to activate and ultimately I to be
okay with that right but you have to
take care of yourself first because you
can't tend to others or to the world
unless you're taking care of yourself
first so that's the first part of
question the second part where are we
headed what are we doing I don't know
we're here today man that's what's
happening that's what's up you know you
know it I don't have like a five-year
plan or a ten-year plan I think I
certainly have ideas that I would like
to see fully Express I'm working on a
new book and there's things like that
but whether it's public speaking or the
podcast or you know whatever it is books
cookbooks music they're all just
different distribution platforms and
mechanisms to try to put a healthy
message out into the world so my only
interest is being able to continue to do
what we do and and to be of maximum
service to the frequency of people like
yourselves that show up and are
vibrating on this wavelength yeah and if
I can just add I have a plant-based
cheese book that's being released in
June it comes out in June 13th I'm
extremely proud of it it's called this
cheese's nut and it was named by our
friends filmmaker Zoe lister-jones and
Darrell wean Darrell actually named it
he actually came to my house and was
tasting my cheese and he was like Julie
you have a title like this cheese is
nuts
so anyway I'm super excited about that
we did a really cool shoot at Farm
Sanctuary the clay shot some incredible
shots with me with Jeanne Bauer's rescue
cows the dairy cows and so I hope you
guys will check that out and then I'm
also very pleased to announce that we
we also created the follow-up to the
plant power way which is coming out in
April 2018 it's plant power Italia and
it's an extraordinary collection of
amazing food so we still trying to
create really great easy recipes to
support all of us in making this very
needed transformation and actually this
is a moment I we had books that are
stuck in customs
unfortunately the plant power way and
Andrew wanted me to mention that the new
normal is actually going to sell them
through their website so they'll be here
in Australia so he'll help you figure
that out if you guys would like to get a
book and don't have it we apologize did
that happen all right you've actually
read one of my questions I'll be lost
but first I'd like to say it's a
privilege to have you guys here tonight
and if you'd love to stay I'm sure
everyone in the room would be happy for
you too but rich two-part question CY
saying what's up with this like how you
guys are so efficient I'm going to wrap
this up tightly
you've obviously shared your experience
along your journey and the challenges
around the financial hardship you faced
as a family what was the turning point
that you realized you could make this
into business to obviously provide for
your family but more importantly after
that when was the actual turning point
that you realized was more than that of
the community great question I don't
know how to answer that or whether I
have a satisfying answer for that I
think the turning point in terms of
knowing that the turning point in terms
of knowing that like we could make a
living doing this is that yeah that we
weren't completely crazy
I remember there kind of one in the same
I remember after doing was after
Ultraman 2009 I think and and Sanjay
Gupta from CNN had taken an interest in
in my story and he was like reading my
blog and I found out about this which
was like blowing my mind in the United
States like a major like News
correspondent guy on television and he
wanted to come out to our house and
view and interview me where she was just
shocking and astounding to me
so we're weathering this crazy sort of
financial meltdown that we were dealing
with and we were having trouble like
paying our utility bills and I remember
Julie wanted to make this beautiful
lunch for him like she wanted him to
like our food and all this sort of stuff
and he was coming out and she she tells
this story where she was like ready to
turn the burner on on the stove and like
praying that the gas was going to work
like this is like we're gonna it was
like this crazy moment of walking the
razor's edge where we were really going
to like realize all our dreams and like
what's happening tonight could be a
possibility for us or we were just going
to wither on the vine and die like it
was going to go either way
luckily the gas worked we were able to
make this lunch for Sanjay Gupta we had
this beautiful experience but in the in
the moment after that happened and
before it aired we thought you know
we're going to be on CNN like we should
be able to probably be a lot of people
coming to our website so maybe we should
have like something we can offer people
so I literally didn't sleep for two days
and created this like PDF cookbook with
Julie's recipes I'm like a hack on
Photoshop but I knew enough to like get
in trouble and put something together
that we could at least make available to
people and we put up this little PDF
cookbook for nine dollars and it was
live on the site when the thing aired
and we got inundated with traffic and
emails and I remember getting so many
emails in the wake of that story airing
it was like they actually CNN let me
write a guest blog post for CNN and it
was also it was on the home page of CNN
that day because it was getting so much
traffic and so our whole world like kind
of exploded and I was getting so many
emails from people sharing the intimate
details of their own personal struggles
and stories and I remember being in the
car with Julie we were driving down the
street and I was on my phone and I was
reading her some of these and I just
started crying like I couldn't believe
that this sort of journey that we were
on I'd suddenly become public and that
it was connecting with people in a
certain way and it was it was very
overwhelming but it was a moment in
which I realized like maybe there's a
way for us to
you know carry this message and and find
a way to do it where we can sustain our
family at the same time and that little
PDF that we created ended up like paying
our bills for two years or something
like that
so those kind of two things happened at
the same time yeah and also on that same
subject is I mean we had many moments
and I want to say that it seemed like
when we were in our darkest moment
because it you know was a trickle it
didn't like solve everything but it
would be a trickle right and then we
were still in our complete destruction
so what would happen is we would be like
break down in Starbucks crying like in
public from the pressure and then one of
you guys would email us and you would be
like we you know you change my life like
you helped me and you guys don't know it
but at that moment like God sent you to
keep us going because it was so hard and
we didn't know we were right on this
razor's edge we were like we're either
going to realize all our dreams or we're
going to be completely annihilated and
it was right down the middle there was
no there was no clear either way and it
was beautiful because Peeta was one of
the first organizations around this time
to take interest in rich and they
invited him to give an award away at
their like Academy Awards in LA and he
was going to share the stage with Alec
Baldwin we had no money and riches none
of Rich's suits from when he was a
lawyer fit him they were like three
sizes too big and I tried I called a
friend of mine laying who owns Planet
Blue and California and I convinced her
to like lonely a dress from the store
that I would return and I tried to fake
like I was a stylist to get him a suit
and no one would give me a suit and we
got a check for 650 bucks from Vitamix
or something like that
and we spent the entire 650 bucks to get
him a proper suit to stand on the stage
it was just these kind of crazy you know
completely illogical things going on it
was a juxtaposition of half
no gas you know no utilities and seen
CNN cameras walking up you know like
most the time we were just like [ __ ] we
sound so irresponsible let's see I think
thank you for your openness and honesty
especially today as well too but firstly
is especially on the vegan diet you find
that sometimes you'll have a hell of a
lot of energy and you can do whatever
you want to do and sometimes you find so
maybe it's pulling back a little bit or
you don't quite have that same pull
towards everything which you need to get
through - so the first part of it is how
do you push through those times and keep
keep on a particular regimental keep
yourself active when it's when it slows
down because naturally you've got to
have done that as an endurance athlete
and the second aspect is where the guys
are doing exercise together because
obviously you're two very different
fitness levels how do you keep
encouraging each other to to sort of
push each other to where your own limits
are as - as opposed to where the high
one is thank you thank you for your
question so the first part I'm trying to
wrap my head around it so the idea that
well first of all you're presupposing
that there are moments where the
plant-based diet doesn't work for me and
I'm having to find a way through it I
don't so as for you but for myself I say
so you're having issues where you're
feeling like is not working for you or
it's not you're not getting the right
energy from it not necessarily but from
whether it's from the plant-based diet
or if it's from if it's from sleep
patterns or if it's from the type of
exercise I'm doing whatever it is have
you run into the same type of same type
of roadblocks or what have you try to
amend or what have you tried to adjust
via Tom okay yeah so well first no I'm
SuperDuper all the time 100% of the time
awesome 24 hours a day
Thank You Julie calls those people super
duper z' you know when you meet you like
you go to a comm hi I'm Jake I'm good
I'm great how are you
you know don't trust those people
they're hiding something yeah of course
I have up and down days I'm very human
I have cravings I'm you know recovering
alcoholic that makes me difficult to
live with Oscar you know my net worth
interface yeah I struggle with
irritability and discontentment and
resentment and fatigue and you know all
the kiya tea like all the kinds of
things that you know I think we all
share as human beings for me a lot of it
is rooted in in 12-step things I've
learned in recovery when I'm not taking
care of myself you know spiritually
mentally emotionally or physically I get
restless irritable and discontent I'm
prone to snap at people and make
improper decisions and be reactive and
amazingly the cure for most of that is
eating a decent meal or getting a good
night's sleep or you know picking up the
phone and getting out of your own head
and your own problem and being of
service to somebody else practicing
gratitude in some respect or another
it's annoying that the cure for these is
always the same I keep looking for the
velvet rope in the VIP room that I can
walk into and graduate from my humanity
but it always I always go back to those
things and and you know I don't do any
of that perfectly by any stretch of the
imagination you have anything to add to
that that was very well said thank you
I'm part about me being difficult to
live yes
I guess you were asking how do we how do
we train together okay so we don't train
together at all ever just I am a
completely different being we have two
completely opposite I can't even imagine
you running no I actually how about look
Lloyd I threatened one I was like I
think I'm going to start riding my bike
and he was like cuz you know if there's
two cyclists in one family that can be
problematic but now I only practice yoga
asana practice and different kinds of
yoga practices that's just my that's my
physical movement of choice and rich is
beautifully supported in extreme
athletics it's just really really good
for him
some of my friends will say to me you
know when you must be like a you know
athletic Widow or something because he
trained so much but I get this really
beautiful quality of human being when
he's completely done all of that and so
yeah we never ever exercise together and
we'd never fight ever and we totally
fight but we always make up more
importantly so so just just quickly to
expend on time so you naturally don't
expect you to train together but how do
you continue to encourage each other to
be pushing forward and to push each
other to your height well I'll into it I
don't push him at all we're both
extremely independent and the focus of
our transformation or our life path is
completely inner one so I think we
respect each other and we have a very
deep commitment between each other and
within that there's an extreme amount of
freedom so I think that's but you have
my back and I have your back and we
understand that so that support is there
yeah thank you
how're you guys gone great so I turned
vegan just over a year ago and then I
researched it and I obviously found your
podcast which gave me loads of tools and
I've really found it really really great
but on a like a deeper sort of level I
was kind of a vegan that was still kind
of heavily drinking and partying a lot
which kind of is a bit of a bit of weird
scenario to be and so I just wanted to
personally thank you both because I've
listened to your podcast especially the
one with Misha Chevalley and I kind of
felt that I didn't need to kind of live
my life to reach a real kind of bottom
and I could just kind of learn from what
you guys spoke about and just in kind of
trying to prove my life that way so
thank you that's all
yeah thank you Mishka walk across town
mister okay all right um where are we
looking ah
hey going yes um I have a one-part
question rebel I have to do okay so
though my on the plane - my wife is in
Adelaide on from Adelaide tonight and
she said say hello to you mate rich she
doesn't like you very much because that
two years ago you inspired me to change
my life and become vegan and I am have
gone from being the under healthiest
person in my house to the healthiest
person in my house
[Music]
so once upon a time you know so was the
garnish on the plate in my opinion and
in meat was what it was all about this
is really a question for you Julie so so
I am now you know looking at my wife
he's a relatively healthy eater by
normal standards but wishing she was you
know where I am today and I imagine you
must have gone through that journey with
rich how did you not become preachy
about about why he needed to change and
how did you remain strong through those
years thank you really great question
and okay so this is a this is actually
very key part of our of our journey
together and that was that I was very
preachy I actually wasn't that preachy
but I had a lot of awareness in the
early days when he was eating the window
diet and he was using using coffee as a
drug literally like a venti coffee with
three ad shots and he was suffering too
he also wasn't happy he wasn't like yeah
this is awesome he was like you know the
alcoholism was clearly activated he was
unhappy so for many years I felt that I
knew how to help him and I would try to
reach to him and I would say here you
know or I was always reading books or
going through transformation or I would
leave something on his pillow or I would
just you know offer something and it was
the craziest thing because it seemed
like the more that I extended myself the
more paralyzed he became he just would
recoil and like just become even worse
and so it was a tricky thing that eluded
me for many years I wasn't that fast of
a learner because I think it took like
seven years of me banging my head
against the wall and I had a lot of
conversations with a lot of girlfriends
who told me how right I was because
clearly I was right because I was
healthy and I healed myself of assists
and I wasn't you know I was advocating
sort of higher concepts of living and it
wasn't until I did a meditation program
with this one Indian master
one of my many Indian masters that I
worked with in my life so many so many
like our house our golfing door of
Indian masters they say they say about
me she she left no rock unturned so if
you have any spiritual questions just
come ask me but anyway he proposed to me
that the concept of human love versus
divine love and he said human love is
simply a business relationship right we
say I love you if you do these things
and then if you don't do these things
then you're you know I'm leaving you
basically so in contrast to divine love
is like the Sun it simply shines on
every part of creation nondiscriminatory
just because so basically we can say
that we are loved simply for our
existence simply for the fact that we
exist before any diets have been
conquered any body types any titles
earned or any goals achieved and you
know when you learn how to ski or snow
ski or surf or whatever and you have
that one-tenth instructor that finally
says that thing to you and you finally
can grab it
this was like this for me and it was at
that moment that I released rich to his
life but I released him to his life and
love I didn't release him to his life in
retaliation and I and I called him and I
said I had had my energy in his space
that I had had an attachment that hit he
realized spiritually the way that I was
in my lifetime and instead I took the
perspective that he was my husband and
we were married and we were in love and
that he also was divine even while
eating in an out burger even while
drinking coffee with three odd shots and
that act of love I really did I embodied
it it was true like it wasn't it was a
clear change but that act of love is in
fact what catalyzed his awakening and
this entire scenario so what should he
do about his wife
I'm just sharing the perspective so he
can see you should love your wife
unconditionally the way she is right now
and keep living the life that you are
living and really understand that there
is a greater play and and just like
people change when they are loved when
they are loved unconditionally we all
want that acceptance and want to be seen
that way and so in my experience from
the story that I just shared with you
it's the most powerful thing that you
can do now is does that mean she's going
to start eating the way that you are you
guys are going to be you know get on the
circuit like I don't know that it's
within your life plan but I will tell
you that there is a great power in
holding somebody in that light and then
you can allow life to kind of have its
way with you and produce something
beautiful in your relationship thank
I found out about your books from Amazon
and probably too many questions I'm
bigging curious so b12 vitamin b12
supplementation do you need to take any
supplement to have a satisfactory diet
second question is when you're on
holidays how do you try to stay vegan or
keep to obtain pace
based diet while you're in a place where
you don't know where all the shops are
or things like that
you look like you have a lovely family
from your books and also wanted to say
because I'm sorry
it's repart er three pods of federal-aid
Allah will you be have the time to Sonia
books to know we would love to sign
books tonight although our books got
held up in customs a few Perl so yeah oh
you brought your boat yeah I think when
we're done here like I'm sure we can
make that arrangement thank you for your
question b12 most doctors would
recommend that you supplement with b12
if you're on a plant-based diet it seems
to be the one vitamin that is missing
from this nutritional regimen and that's
a whole conversation I'm happy to have
with anybody it has to do with soil and
etc it's kind of boring but yeah b12 but
I think everybody needs to should or I
would recommend everybody get a proper
blood test and evaluate what your
various deficiencies may or may not be
and sort of act you know from there
there's a lot of people that are vitamin
D deficient etc etc Andrew would be a
much better person to answer all of
those questions than I the second
question was remaining vegan while you
travel it's easy to future trip about
that like oh my god I have to go to a
wedding in a year what am I going to eat
you know I can't go vegan now
I traveled all I've been to crazy places
I've been to Pakistan I've been to
Lebanon a couple times I've been to
three cities in Saudi Arabia then in
Morocco I've been a lot of places and
I've always been able to maintain a
plant-based diet no matter where I go
now that doesn't mean that I'm going to
get it exactly the way that I want it
and I'm certainly not going to get the
kind of food that Julie makes at home
but I've always been able to make it
work and you know there's a couple
practices that that are helpful with
that I try to stay in hotel rooms that
have a little kitchenette which makes it
a little bit easier if you're flying
somewhere maybe once you land go
directly you know search on your phone
we have these super computers in our
pockets they're very powerful they
answer a lot of questions you can find
out where the natural food market is go
there before you even check into the
hotel get what you need you know always
have healthy options like within arm's
reach make sure you bring a lot of
snacks on your long flight there's an
app called happy cow it will tell you
where all the vegan restaurants are no
matter where you travel throughout the
world and when you're in restaurants
that perhaps don't seem like they're
going to be vegan friendly you can
approach the waitstaff and pleasantly
inquire what they might be able to make
for you that might be off the menu I've
always had good experiences with that
and have been able to make it work so a
lot of that I've learned is sort of
imagined projection that we think it's
going to be a lot harder than it
actually turns out to be do anything
that on that yeah exactly and then a
couple things are in the early days we
used to travel with our Vitamix if it's
if you're driving somewhere we just
bring the Vitamix with so that's another
thing and then if you're going out to
dinner and you don't know if there's
going to be vegan options we we get in
the habit of just eating before we go so
if there's only a side salad or there's
a potato but that's not really travel as
much but potato cool all right thank you
yeah thank ya thanks for coming we gotta
wrap it up how much you guys
thank you loving to be very fulfilled
the guys